I want everyone to do a really solid
inventory of everyone they've ever dated
it's so important and it's a step that
many people don't do I really literally
need you to go through every single
person you've had a significant
relationship with and I want you to
write down the qualities they have that
are a yes for you and the qualities they
have that are know for you you can get a
picture of what are their red flags the
nose that keep coming up when you see
that pattern then you have to do the
really hard work of looking at yourself
and saying okay what was the crazy and
me that attracted that crazy five times
I'm joined by Amanda CUDA Amanda welcome
Michelle
very good to have you here what we sing
about the combination of blue blocking
glasses and mustache at the moment
they're great it's good I like the look
definitely it's good podcast I want to
start a podcast with barefaced lies that
are also compliment at the same time
it's a compliment but I'm like how would
I respond if I saw you in the real world
and didn't know you you're some guy out
on the street and I'm passing you and
you have to hold this look going on I
think I look great some young someone
said that it was a little bit of a
freddy mercury sort of thing going on
with the mustache and the glasses I
thought a bit cooler than that I thought
like a waist this may be but it doesn't
you know it doesn't matter they're raw
optics so Matt maruka the guy from raw
optics will be on soon CEO and creator
of the light diet so in podcast I'm yeah
in Pakistan that may have come out
before this or after this so you know
just it's like pick-and-mix listeners
don't you're gonna get so what are we
going to talk about today we are going
to talk about you know you've had a
couple of episodes about dating in the
modern world but they were they didn't
have a lot of tips like how do you
actually become a modern date or how do
you actually do the thing and I just
want to jam on what are some practical
slash maybe a little out there things
that you could be doing that are going
to give you a like leg up in the market
a leg up being both metaphorical and
physical yes exactly
as
love it I put a post up a little while
ago I think before we knew each other at
the start this year that said true love
in 2020 is finding someone that you
could date sober yes do you think that's
true
oh my goodness a hundred percent I mean
you know that I don't drink and that for
me is a lifestyle I don't see any
situation where I'll go back to it I
know that you you say that you might do
it every now and then right toggle back
and forth but I don't see anywhere where
it adds to my life and especially in
dating I have seen as a dater where it
completely detract from the situation
and even though it's a scary thing to go
out into the dating world saying I'm
doing this stone-cold sober it's
actually a hundred percent of value-add
what what bad situations have you been
in when someone's were now that you or
the other person's got drunk or been
drinking or that you've heard from your
friends oh man you know I mean every
dating situation for my 20s on was
lubricated with alcohol so up until the
time I was 32 I guess every single
flirting dating first kiss first time
all of that was all drinking or drunk
right and I just look back and I think
that's completely unproductive how did I
even know if I was attracted to the
person let alone if we had chemistry or
anything and dating as a sober person is
I well I you don't usually say sober I
say alcohol free just because it's like
a little bit of a different of a brand
but dating in that market has been so
interesting but so bad experience is
there I mean you have to negotiate are
you going to look for a partner that
also doesn't drink are you going to tell
the person you don't drink which yes you
should I can tell you a story about how
that's turned out very badly and and how
do you how do you go into this knowing
that you're going to be fully vulnerable
and you're just you're just you that's
it you don't have any sort of any sort
of social lubricant to break you know
break the break the ice yes I mean
straight off everyone that's listening
think about the last time that you went
on a date sober or if you've ever been
on a date sober and I this doesn't count
like if you needed to invite a friend
- like a child's birthday party or
something like that doesn't correct
because you can okay well it's like a
three a toddler's barbecue or something
you're not allowed to drink or it's a
wacky warehouse or something that does
nothing - and you totally right like
people use alcohol as a butcher's for
their confidence - this scaffolding that
they wrap around their lives and I'm
totally sweet like if you want to go out
you want to use alcohol and stuff to
bolster your confidence that's fine my
argument has always been I think will
remain to be no matter what I'm doing
with regards to drinking that unless you
take a period focus period away from
alcohol to actually work out what are my
capacities without this augmentation
that is drinking you you never actually
know where your skills lie it's like
being a power lifter or a bodybuilder or
something and always being on a
performance-enhancing drug throughout
your whole career right yeah but there's
performance-enhancing drug it's making
you be better at the things you're
trying to do and giving you skills which
technically you don't have and you let
right okay so do you have those skills
well I do but they're not intrinsic
they're kind of this weird combination
of what I'm capable of doing with the
assistance of this thing and then you
think okay so you know with taking
alcohol away giving yourself the
opportunity to actually have to develop
genuine confidence to get over what's
referred to in pickup artistry is
approach anxiety you know you to
actually develop that is a real
eye-opener yeah no absolutely and I
think I've even dug a little deeper into
that more recently and and you know I
work with women who also are either
wanting to quit drinking or they have
already quit drinking and so we have
this conversation a lot and one of the
big things is well how you know how do I
go into a date and be confident what is
it not going to limit my the dating pool
and all of those things and yes but it's
going to limit your dating pool to do a
smaller more attractive group of people
in the end and what that one of the
things that I really dug into is okay
what is this like the subliminal message
you're sending to your your subconscious
when you go out on a date and you
have to drink and okay so if you're
going if you're going on a date what are
some reasons you might want to drink
Chris what do you think is adding to the
experience being honest it's been so
long since I drank too regularly and
even longer since I dated like I can't
remember if you held a gun to my head
right now and said when was the last
time you went on a date I couldn't tell
you but thinking right right back it
would have been a combination of I don't
know if this girl or date is going to be
sufficiently interesting for me to keep
energy high I don't know if I have
sufficient confidence I don't know if I
can get over my approach anxiety
sometimes I might have used a date as
pre-drinks to a night out when I might
have been going out with my buddies is
like pull the ripcord
like you're warmer this is the this
dates going badly right I'm sorry I see
you later on that was great and then
I'll sneak off to a club or whatever
forget most of those but I think a good
amount of it would be improved
confidence getting over approach anxiety
stuff like that for sure and the most
common answers are exactly that you know
you want to UM be more be able to speak
more freely you want have more
confidence you want to feel looser you
want to feel sexy or whatever those
things are you know for men and women
they're probably a little bit different
but if you look at the reverse the
antithesis of that that is saying I
don't feel myself worth is good enough
that I could possibly reach that feeling
of feeling and confident sexy engaging
interesting on my own I do not feel
confident enough in that so therefore I
need something to help me get there and
if I look at it in that perspective I
don't want to date someone who has that
like hidden mind said that they do not
feel confident enough that they can have
a conversation with me without and be
interesting and be interested without a
substance that just doesn't bode well
for our relationship in my mind I agree
completely at this this is a red pill
that I'm actually having to do a little
bit of work to get myself back to the
realization it's like learning that your
sleep quality is better when you phones
outside of your room and then
remembering what it used to be like when
you had your phone
still in your bedroom and you're like oh
god I actually used to do that and it's
like I used to think that drinking was
just par for the course with rating
where is now that red pill is so far
down me that I can't get it back out
yeah
no well and take the list up further you
know one of the things that one of the
like really harsh red pills we have to
all swallow is that most of our parents
didn't do didn't have the ability to
give us the tools to learn how to
emotionally regulate properly and just
kind of this might not seem totally
related but just go with me here so your
parents don't have the skills to say
okay Chris oh you're feeling sad how
does that how does that feel not totally
dick you know dis your mom and dad but
I'm imagining 90% of our parents didn't
do this they didn't say Chris you're
feeling sad I'm so sorry how does that
feel where do you feel it in your body
like tell me about sadness Chris and or
tell me about anger tell me about
anxiety where do you feel that in your
body how does it feel a process it most
parents are like oh let me take that
from you let me take that pain or anger
and anxiety and take it on as a parent
or let me try and distract you and brush
it away or let me tell you that big boys
or big girls don't cry and you should
just stop doing that so we grow up with
this and then will you reach out a
lessons we have to go out and learn to
regulate on our own and if we haven't
been given the skills to do so guess
what no worries
society has a secret substance like a
little liquid gold for that and so you
can just drink your anxiety your fear
your sadness whatever you can just take
this magic elixir and it's gone so then
you're coming into the world the adult
world with really really highly stunted
emotional growth you don't have any clue
how to properly regulate yourself in
your emotions and I say again do I
really want to be in a relationship
either me coming to the table as that
person or me dating the person on the
other side of the table that doesn't
know how to regulate themselves except
for with alcohol not really I do say I
need to kind of wave a little bit of a
flag here that it might sound to some of
the people who haven't swallowed this
red pill yet I haven't gone alcohol-free
for a little while like we're saying
that all of you are somehow flawed and
using alcohol is this coping mechanism
what we're saying is that alcohol isn't
being used
in a conscious way it's not being used
deliberately by you it's not something
and there will be some people out there
that just that you know what it is I
just love a glass of wine and it's like
yeah yeah we're not talking to you
well I obviously obviously we're not
talking to you but the vast majority of
people it's just not conscious use right
it's not deliberate alcohol use on the
whole forget the dating side of stuff
alcohol use on the whole is just
habituated it's done because it's what
you've always done it done and it was
done then because it's what everybody
else did so you've got this weird like
mimetic thing going on where it's passed
down my daddy did it and his daddy
before him and you know like that's I my
mommy and daddy met so I know you're in
Texas I'm allowed to say that yes know
for sure I I it's not anyone who drinks
isn't it fundamentally flawed but anyone
who drinks at a like a decent level
guaranteed you have to believe that that
substance is either helping you achieve
a desired outcome or avoid an
undesirable outcome and from that
perspective it's not a neutral in your
life right you're always trying to drink
it or you know use it to get somewhere
that's more desirable than where you are
right now and that's kind of a dangerous
place to be and definitely when it comes
to dating yeah I agree
so tell us some of the tips what are
some of the things that we can do cos
whip me new both in our thirties and
both single I'm not sure whether you're
quite as hopeless as I am but both very
both very single actually hyper in
lockdown you're like as single as it's
possible to be oh yeah yeah there's
nothing out there there's nobody no one
in my apartment complex I'm just a lady
with two dogs talking to the camera Will
Smith I am Legend in the [ __ ] out of it
right now yeah that's what's going on
okay so give us give us some tips okay
so the first tip that I I want to give
everyone especially if you find that you
continue to date kind of the same type
of person throughout your history I want
everyone to do a really solid inventory
of everyone they've ever dated and that
sounds a little time-consuming but it's
so important and it's a step that many
people don't do so let me detail what
that is
maybe maybe you've done it or maybe some
people listening have done it but I
guarantee that the bulk of people
haven't so we you do an inventory I want
you to go through and just make like a
simple sheet of paper fold it in half
and put it on one side like yes and once
I know and I really literally need you
to go through every single person you've
had a significant relationship with and
I want you to write down the qualities
they had that are a yes for you and the
qualities they have that are know for
you and what you can do from this
landscape is you can get a picture of
number one what are the red flags the
nose that keep coming up and I would
guarantee if you you're thinking about
it right now I guarantee you could spot
between like two or three people what
some of the same kind of nose are or
what some of the same like those aren't
so great qualities are and when you see
that pattern then you have to do the
really hard work of looking at yourself
and saying okay what was what was the
crazy and me that attracted that crazy
five times like what is the world trying
to tell me what do I need to look at
that I keep getting that same scenario
because it's not the guy or the girl
it's me I'm the common denominator right
so I'm trying to think about the yeses
and the good things what's interesting
for me is I'm trying to do it in my head
is many of the things which I have that
common attraction attractors amongst the
girls that I've dated also come with
some malignant side effects which are
probably linked to the nose as well so
for instance I tend to go for girls who
are more type-a quite driven grey like
that's good it means that where growth
minded it means that they're always
going to be prepared to do things
together on the know side of that it
makes them incredibly disagreeable and
because I'm quite high in
disagreeableness that means that we end
up clashing so okay uni it's I think a
lot of these are going to kind of come
as pairs right with some of them and
it's going to be okay can I try and find
someone who has part of the yes but
maybe doesn't have all of the know sure
sure I know that's a really important
distinguishing factor but you also you
can
someone who is high in argument like
argue ability and also just knows how to
alkalize an argument to where it's you
and them against the fight against this
other thing versus you against them and
that's a big difference between someone
who maybe is just at the next level of
the type that type of person you've been
dating right and you can only see that
and see the pattern once you really get
clear on okay here are all the lovely
things about Janet here are all the
things about Janet that annoyed the [ __ ]
out of me and that I don't really want
to attract an another partner and how
can I work through those things that are
annoying as [ __ ] about all of my
partners and ask myself why am I so
argumentative is there something that is
in me that has to be right or I'm trying
to prove myself or you know I have like
this little shadow in my past that
someone embarrassed me for being wrong
and that I can work through that and be
a better partner myself and then I can
just stop attracting you know this type
of specific person and it's been really
enlightening for me like my specific
pattern on the note well it's you you
need to do this exercise in a couple of
ways it's yes as a nose and then it's
also additional qualities so some people
when they make a list of what their
partner looks like it's like you know
tall blond hair blue eyes whatever
they're going for physical things and of
course I'm gonna encourage you to go
more for I'm attracted to this person
right not like this person has to look
like this for me to be attracted to them
can't you just write down I'm attracted
to this person and or they're physically
attractive to me and not be enough and
that can evolve in whatever way it is
and that in in how that person comes to
you but what this does is it gives you
this really clear list of who you're
looking for and allows you to go back
and look at are there any stuck points
here because let's say you're talking
about I don't know who sorry for all the
Janet's out there cuz I'm just gonna
like go down the rabbit hole jog on
we've already said this before that if
your name is Janet Karen or Sharon right
now the Internet is a terrible place I
watched I watched a video the other day
that was called the Karen pocalypse
which was about all of these sort of mid
50s women mostly American
have been like re-released into the wild
and they're just going crazy screaming
it blew in like it's always in a
supermarket carpark against the security
yes and then Ben Shapiro last week
tweeted facts don't Karen about your
feelings
that's so good Karen Janet so it also
allows you to go back and see if you
have any unresolved feelings with any of
these people so maybe you look at Janet
and you still feel a little lustrous a
little bit of like oh what if that could
work out again or you look at Janet
you're like Jim it's a cold hard [ __ ]
like I can't I don't ever want to think
about her again and those are both kind
of like personal red flags to me because
it says that I'm still eager
romanticizing something about this
person or I haven't let something go
because anyone who I feel like I have to
talk crap about basically in my life
there's some there's another thing there
that I need to look about look at if I
can't look at a person with pure
appreciation and say you know Steve
isn't was in my life to teach me this
lesson and yeah he did also some crummy
things but I can look past those then I
then I still have something to look out
there there's still something that's
agitating me about that relationship and
just kidding all of these things out on
a list reminiscing and deciding okay do
I have you know am i romanticizing this
person am i making them too perfect am i
am i making them you know kind of more
of a double character in my life and how
can I come to a neutral and how can I
take all of the things I liked about
that person and say hey perhaps all of
these people were brought to me to show
me that these characteristics exist in
individual people and that could I just
imagine for just one moment that they
could all be found in one single
individual and and that that's a
possibility for me and when I go out on
a date that I say you know what this is
what I've said that I want I'm not gonna
stay on this track I'm not gonna keep
going out with this person unless they
meet this list that I have and and
really just pulling confidence that that
could actually exist because so often
we're told no it doesn't yeah I've got a
damn thing that I really I've been
thinking about a lot recently that I
want to get onto to do with that before
that one of the things I've realized
that I've done in the past
is hard a relationship or whatever with
a girl for a while and then it's ended
either my side her side mutual or
whatever it might be but if I've had
unresolved attraction towards her I've
then tried the next few girls that I've
ended up dating or the ones that I've
been putting ground working with oh my
they look they kinda seem an awful lot a
little bit like the one from before a
little bit I look at them me like am I
am I like just trying to recreate this
guy trying to find the thing especially
if it's unrequited right especially if
it's the sort of thing where it was
finished by the other person you're like
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna find her but
better it's like yeah so that's one
thing second thing I'm thinking about is
when you talk about putting stuff down
on paper first off it's the most
effective way to actually become
conscious of your thought processes
right the reason why morning pages is
such a big thing from junior camera and
it's the reason why mourning gratitude
and an evening cooldown Rutina are
important as well hashtag six minute
diary everyone knows what I'm on about
but it brings up some pretty ugly stuff
because if you've never done it before
you realize just how big the size of the
septic tank is that all of your feelings
have been swimming around in festering
there's this weird like oily film on the
top of it and you got to even get
through the oily film before you can
even get to like and there's lumps in it
yeah there's lumps at the bottom then at
the bottom there's like sludge and you
kind of gotta get a shovel out and it's
very uncomfortable is my point like self
introspective work is one of the most
uncomfortable things in the world and
the saddest part about it is that it
never finishes like you never stop doing
self inquiry it's not like oh yay like
actualized off-off I go to go and sit in
the sunshine like that's not a way
that's not the way it works
isn't that the exciting part about it
though that you get to keep you don't
just like get to this level and you're
like okay I think that's exciting it's a
bit exciting but to me
also a little bit like a an infinity
game of pass the parcel so you pass the
parcel and you unwrap it and you're like
oh yay like did a little bit more self
inquiry there like one one level through
but you never actually get to the parcel
there's no parcel there's just wrapping
and you're like Oh for [ __ ] sake yeah
it's 70 77 years old having meditated
for 50 years and all the self-inquiry in
the world a just looking at it and
you're like I just got more wrapping
paper here this is just someone said
there's a parcel inside so but yeah
that's that's that final thing my final
little train of thought that can close
is from the daniel schloss podcaster did
Daniel's the Scottish comedian very
famous appeared on Netflix and HBO and
stuff like that and he says something
similar to what you've just said which
is I have standards that I want my
partner to meet now the problem and this
is something I'm going to put to you the
challenge that you have is most people's
dating that I see or a lot of people's
dating that I see is done unconsciously
more more people than don't as far as
I'm concerned choose to be in a
relationship out of a fear of being
alone rather than a desire to be with
the person that their width they choose
something which is the closest proxy to
a person that will make them happy
rather than the person that they
actually want they're like yeah yeah you
look you look about right like if we
miss you're good enough if we like just
tap that down a little bit on the top
and get enough if I ignore this part of
your personality and if I forget the
fact that I've got this level of either
attraction or an attraction to you and
it's not any other um but the
implication of that is if you decide to
set these standards out if you take the
red pill and if you decide to become
fully conscious of all of these
different things the likelihood of you
finding somebody who meet all of these
fully aware criteria that you have
starts to go down quite sharply sure
yeah okay so anything's to cover here
let me wrap let me brought back her onto
the start of your comments oh yeah slam
that down the the first part is you know
reott r acting the same type of person
because you're trying to find a quality
that you that you
that you felt was like just unrequited
and another person and I have a couple
of things there so one of my mentors
Gabby Bernstein she says show up for
what's up or it'll keep coming up and
it's just a reminder that you gotta
clean up your side of the street to stop
you know stop attracting those things
that are undesirable or that are
repetitive patterns but also sometimes
you just have to I'm gonna get a little
like woowoo here I don't I I'm a
meditator I know you are as well but
like a really specific thing you can do
and that's in that situation is do some
sort of a cord-cutting meditation where
you just sit and you you envision the
two of you going your separate ways
peacefully you could like you know
partner that with some sort of
affirmation like I'm willing to release
this person and a hold that they have
over me in my heart and just help me to
release this like burden or this like
tie I have to this person because it's
not productive for you or for them to to
have this like emotional bond left and
you don't have to call them and say hey
I'm over you you can you can do that
work within yourself to release it right
you don't have to have any contact with
that person and it feels so frame when
you're no longer chasing that quality or
that person in someone else like it's
just this weight off of your your
shoulders so so there's that I would
just definitely recommend for anyone
who's going through that similar
situation where you're kind of stuck or
hung up on someone or some
characteristic that someone had that you
can't seem to replicate anywhere to do
some sort of like core cutting
meditation you could just google it and
find one that you'll be guided through
and it'll be great
okay the next the next thing you also
mentioned you know having like just two
high standards I guess and I I get it
like I do like you start to make this
list of who is your fantasy like prince
or princess charming you know whatever
whatever that looks like in your world
and it starts to I'm a little
unrealistic and yes you do what you may
have to make some compromises of you
know okay so the person doesn't have to
look exactly like this or maybe you
start to get more broad because here's
the thing are little like creative minds
are not as creative as the possibility
in the world so
I think right now that I want I could be
completely I that could just be part of
some like weird elaborate hallmark
fantasy that I that I've created right
yeah there could be something way better
out there but I put myself in this
little box of this is exactly the person
who I want to have so you also have to
like give the universe and like the
powers that be some sort of creative you
know creative license here as well yeah
the number of times that friends that I
know have quite prescriptive ideas about
the sort of person that they want I
always want a girl who goes to the who's
like in fitness or I want to a guy who's
real tall and dark and handsome or
whatever it is and it's the female
artist or the the dude that's actually
like a low-key guitar player that's only
five foot ten like that comes in and
they're the ones that absolutely
annihilate them because they completely
break down all of the preconceptions
that they had your I think almost one of
the reasons that we like to keep going
for people that are similar and almost
it's a failing of the what's your type
question mentality is that you know what
you're in for
you would much sooner be unhappy in a
familiar way than risk being incredibly
happy with something that's new because
the coping mechanisms that you need to
deal with the breakup of the new thing
require an awful lot more learning
you're like oh I don't know how I deal
with the breakup with the artist girl
like I was great dealing with the
breakup with the fitness girl like
because I did it five times like she is
easy but this one's got charcoal on her
hands and she wears a beret and we used
to go to art galleries together and
you're like oh okay
so I think again a lot of that like this
is again what we say like self inquiry
it's just this never [ __ ] ending
vortex like playing past the parcel when
you think yeah yeah yeah I got it
there's my buyer sees gone any like that
make now you're so wrong no for sure
it's always it's always another you're
I'm always learning something every
person I date I'm like wow I didn't know
that I wanted that or I didn't
I didn't know that that bothered me and
it's just this ever evolution but that's
another thing like always anytime you
date someone add back to that list of
qualifications because you always get
something new that you're like whoa I
really dig that about you know this
person and how they did that or how they
got on in the world and like keep adding
on to that list my friends because it
just unless you have this like long list
of things that you know you like and you
know that you're not that into you're
gonna go into the next situation and
then you'll start to like oh well but it
or you'll forget you know there was this
one little thing that is kind of a deal
breaker and it's just so good to have
that to have that standing but in in
context of dating today you know I think
that looking at that from the dating app
perspective is really interesting
because then you're just given like this
visual portfolio of someone and you
start to really rely on what is my type
who is that person and I think that it's
really convoluted the dating game in a
really [ __ ] way do you have you have you
been online day I may not it's so weird
when people ask that question but I felt
compelled to I don't know why I even
asked it like who that single hasn't
used tinder like for sure you know
tender all you use there in the UK do
you guys not have anything like higher
caliber like Bumble or something or do
people does not use that so I was seen a
girl about two and a half years ago and
someone made a fake profile of me on
bumble okay she was adamant absolutely
adamant that it was actually me and my
replace them what yeah and I was like
look I'm telling you I'm telling you
that it's not centered like swipe down
from the top of my application so I was
like look if I type in B um nothing
comes up which was unfortunate because
it could have been like Amanda great
bomb 2019 or something like that I was
like I don't I don't have the app and
she was still adamant and I was that
right okay you've decided to push the
button far too far so I was just like
look you're gonna make yourself look
really stupid here and then just became
scathing that one situation it was maybe
a like a five minute spearhead and then
the subsequent like two or three days of
it of it burbling down in her realizing
that she was wrong
that was attraction over for me I was
like yeah there you go five minutes
you killed it off see that run thanks
for saving me sometime sister now and
stuff like that they are on over here
what's the what's the premiere what's
what's like the gold standard dating app
over in America you know I would say
it's probably bumble right now just
there they're the hot one but you know
the the brand of tinder is definitely
more hookup culture so that's not what I
even play with but I think that no
matter where you're using dating apps I
use to I wouldn't into it with a really
bad attitude for the longest time and
you know what when you go into something
with a bad attitude damn straight you're
gonna get bad results so I would love to
share some tricks that I use to kind of
like game the system and use all of
these things more intentionally because
I guarantee if you are disciplined
enough to put some of these things into
practice that you will get much better
results off of whatever app your blog I
want to tender discipline or Bumble
discipline that's what that's what we're
here for
okay got it so all right so in terms of
I would have talked about a few things I
wanna talk about your profile I want to
talk about some rules for engaging with
people and I want to talk about actually
your rules like some rules for using the
app itself so the first thing is you
know if you look at a bumble a tender
whatever it's like a social media game
right it's an endorphin hit the entire
time and if you let yourself treat it as
that it's that's all you're going to get
in results it's always going to be just
another Instagram another Facebook
another whatever you know game you're
playing and how many times have you sat
down before you get to get on bumble or
you get to get on tinder how how many
times have you sat down you just like
close your eyes and meditate it and say
you know let me think about the partner
who I want to like call in on this app
or who I want to meet let me think about
who that person is have you ever done
that how about no I haven't no it
usually it's for me it's when I'm bored
you know yes oh yeah or what I'm someone
new because obviously I'm far too much
of a cheapskate to pay for tinder Pro so
yeah like I'll go somewhere I'll go
somewhere on holiday and use up 100
swipes a day of like trying to oh this
is interesting maybe she'll go and to be
fair in my defense it's worked out
really phenomenally for meeting cool
people so I've made a fantastic friend
that I'm still mates with two and a half
years later from Iceland when I was in
Iceland I managed to get backstage in
front of a quarter of a million people
on the 4th of July in Nashville with
Brett Eldredge this year it is because
of tinder so it's not like it's like I
feel like and now that you know that
you've given the hierarchy to it I feel
like I'm I'm all seedy down here in the
music okay anyway um so well here's the
thing though like if you're going on
tinder if you're going on any of these
to like make friends real quick or find
a hookup or whatever you know that's a
different intentionality but if you
actually want to meet someone who's
dateable who you want to spend some time
with like wood in it then you know make
more sense to sit down and say okay this
is my five minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes
a day I'm going to devote to looking for
someone who I want to date rather than
I'm watching you know whatever on
Netflix and let me pop this up so I feel
like meaning through yeah I mean in my
defense on those examples in my defense
I was just looking for backstage tickets
to Broderick so Jerry that worked that
worked out fine that was one for once
successes yeah but yeah and again like I
think part of the transactional nature
and the easy come easy go way that these
apps are done and also with kind of like
young hookup culture and stuff like that
as well the intention isn't there for
most people to use it properly but if
they actually ask themselves like why am
I on tinder like if you want to hook up
it's in terms of a time investment
perspective it's significantly quicker
for you to just go on a night out in a
club after midnight like you'll pull far
more easily that way if that's what
you're after so if you're gonna put your
time in on these sorts of apps you're
right it makes sense to be like right
okay so why am I here why am i why am i
bothering to even spend my time on this
I have everything else in the universe
that isn't a dating app to be doing with
my time right now why am I here yes
absolutely
so if you if you instead set of time
especially if you're into productivity
right you know if you set it hide like
this is my this is my time to look for
partner focus clean or my friend set
aside your time and and instead of like
doing it in the grocery line that's just
passive you know time pass it's just
doesn't help so I'm not saying like this
is the end all be all but I'm just
saying when I do this I get much better
results because I have said this is what
I'm showing up for and this is what I
expect to get and it's just kind of like
manifestation magic like you you get
what you are game for so be a little
more intentional about the time you use
and also when you're getting on to
respond to things and when you're not
when you're checking your messages it's
just like with anything Instagram or
Facebook can become complete waste of
time and just like mindless activities
that you do and so can a dating app so
get on at five o'clock and this is when
you're responding to messages for a
while until you switch to texting with
someone and then that's a different
relationship so that's my like number
one rule is just be intentional about
when you're using the app and what
you're doing because mindless activity
gets you mindless results and you know
if you're there for that that's cool but
if you actually want a high-caliber
partner you're not gonna get it with
just like randomly swiping cool what's
next okay so oh man i I just feel so I
need to teach people how to set up a
proper proper profile I don't I maybe
I'm just looking at the men's side of
course I only get to see men's profiles
they suck they're really bad guy what
are the key mistakes that guys make all
right so guys and girls make these as
well but I'm and I've looked at plenty
of my girlfriend's profiles who are
doing this as well so girls like listen
up this is something you can improve on
as well but first of all you get six
pictures right
you have sick opportunities to show
someone else what you look like and I
have some pretty strong rules for myself
of what I will put there and I think the
other person should have that too so let
me tell you I'm gonna sound a little
crazy but it works let me tell you first
of all no more than one picture where
you can't see your full face so that
means sunglasses hat or or you're far
away so you can have you have a picture
of you with your sunglasses but that's
it you cannot have any other picture
where you're hidden because
I know I need to know if I want to meet
you in public then I can pick you out in
a crowded room I don't want to be like
oh is that Chris I can't tell him
because he has four like dog filled a
snuggler
no filters no don't yes you cannot use
any filters like Jesus please the girls
you are the worst at this like no flower
crown just be like a picture of yourself
for God's sakes it's a part doing the
flower crown or doing like the dog photo
is making a profile for your
girlfriend's to see it's like no unless
you're unless you've selected like I'm
interested in women like what do ya I
got it I feel like and I feel like for
guys like stop reporting that behavior
makes that a hard look less like don't
even cares like do your snapchat filters
out of here
so basically five of the six pictures
need to be where I can see you full body
that means I don't want to five pictures
of you and all your bros because then
I'm trying to figure out who you are how
do I know which one of you are in there
all right I'm doing in and like which
one is he
they all need to be within the last year
um you need to have at least one that's
like full body and not like you know you
don't have to be like showing off your
body but at least I can see the rest of
you and and so and then also only one
action shots so great you're an
adventurer you go on tons of vacations
but you're like a little blip out here
in the snow and a snow suit that cool
like I'm so glad you're an expert skier
but I can't see who you are as a person
you could tell me I like to ski and I
could make that picture of any person in
a snow suit a million feet away in the
snow right I don't need your
visualization help I love it okay so
that's that's how we set up our profiles
we've got we've got our little rules for
for photos you listen to the episode I
did with Rob Henderson didn't you about
the difference in conversions so anyone
who's listening who didn't listen to
this go back and check our episode with
Rob Henderson on the evolution in the
date in modern date market was like so
good and in that he said that
essentially girls swipe right about one
in eight to one in ten times and
sometimes can go through entire periods
like entire
batches of work on tinder or whatever
without even swiping right once whereas
guys tend to swipe in the opposite
direction they tend to not swipe like 1
in 8 to 1 in 10 times the difference in
conversion for guys is if you have a
bachelor's degree in your bio you'll
tend to convert around about 20% better
and if you have a master's degree in
your bio you'll then convert at another
20% better as well which and that's like
this isn't me right saying that girls
only go for guys who are educated or a
wealthy this facts don't Karen about
your feelings okay [ __ ] do not Karen
about your feelings also I would posit
that women put more effort into their
profiles right they are putting on small
and so I [ __ ] I'd much rather go through
a woman's like profile than men's
because I get something like visual to
see where okay you're not and so putting
the work I guaranteed that statistic
would change if the men were putting in
more work into getting pictures and I
get it like it's uncomfortable to take
take photos you maybe you don't have a
ton of yourself but you have a frigging
high-caliber camera in your phone
everyone has it like a you know how to
use in a flip phone anymore that has a
[ __ ] camera like everyone has an HD
camera in their hand set up a self-timer
figure this figure it out you can take a
selfie you can take a picture of
yourself like those pictures can be
created if you do not have that no I'm
gonna I'm gonna put a couple of caveats
in as well from some stuff that I've
picked up over the years yeah if you are
a guy it's a fairly good idea to have at
least one photo where you were in a
group that has other girls in and make
the girls at least moderately attractive
the reason being that you want to look
like a well-rounded guy one you're
signalling I am someone that other girls
want to spend time with not some total
weird freak I think you probably need to
have a top line barrier of maybe 50%
selfies like I do me you don't want to
look like a mouth-breathing basement
dweller
who has so you know like get just if
you've got the full-frame thing even if
you like you say if you've kind of mess
around with the with the self-timer and
like just probably thrown up with some
books at least you can you can fake
having friends I'm friends at these
books okay so we got we got the
intentionality in the pre the pre bumble
meditation we've got the the guidance on
setting up your profile what's next you
know the other thing that's frustrating
is just the communication factor and how
unintentional some people are and I'm
sure you've had plenty of outreach on
you you know either tinder or Instagram
or someone just says hi right or they or
even worse like a passive like where
they just like thumbs up a photo and
expect that to be enough to give a be a
conversation starter and I know girls
are just as that is just a gift from
girls is the one like if I get if I get
another one because I don't watch
friends I don't know who any of the
characters are but there's like some
some guy from friends or some girl from
friends or something this like famous
friend's gif like how are you doing or
something that's written below yeah like
there is an entire Internet of gifts out
there the fact that I've received that
gift so many times that I can recall it
means like that that game is now
outlawed for the rest of time yeah yeah
hear that ladies it's not the way to
Chris's heart yeah it's it's it's so
passive and if you wanted to meet
someone organically at the grocery store
you would not exude that kind of
behavior right you wouldn't just go up
to them and like smile or creatively
thumbs up and that would be super creepy
you would say hello how are you or you
say hello have you tried this quinoa
before you know you'd ask them a
question
that's like relevant to the situation he
wasn't you wouldn't just stare at them
and like Hello do you know what do you
know where the feminine-hygiene or the
erectile-dysfunction aisle is maybe not
that one but yes something's something
in that vein yes ask good ask the
question so same thing with a dating an
athlete ask a Sinkin question ask a
question and not like
not something you know I have I'm not
gonna give away my best one because I
sell that to other people but there are
some really good questions you can ask
that are open-ended that get to like I
care about you I either read your
profile I'm ready to engage with you but
it's just so frustrating when you get a
high hello
I'm not even gonna try I'm gonna put the
ball back in your court because I don't
have enough you know confidence or time
to actually start a conversation with
you so always start a conversation
ladies and gentlemen both of you yeah I
guess even if you if you don't ask a
question the implication of you just
alerting the other person to your
existence is this is now a job for you
to do yeah yeah for sure and it's it's
just putting it's making the other
person work super hard so like give us
it I'm gonna use the leg up as it throws
a [ __ ] bone that's a bone yes you got
it you got it okay okay what else so so
those are like the main rules for just
like navigating the dating apps the
other things that I like to put into
place this sounds like I'm like a badass
and have like all these rules like
you're never gonna get past this stone
wall here but that's not true I'm just
very very intentional and the other
thing is when you actually are going out
on dates and I've seen so many people
like really screw this up and do this a
very very casual way so I'm gonna tell
you I have a three rural date and that
is nothing to do with sex
it is this there are three dates you
have to go on three dates that are
actually like meaningful dates where you
get to know a person and I actually like
to look at them more as like a meet-up
because if I'm just meeting you for the
first time I don't know if I like wanna
date you were go on a date with you if I
met you on a dating app or even in the
grocery store so can we not just look at
it as we're gonna have a casual you know
hangout where we decide can we be
friends and for me that looks like you
have to be able to hear the person so
you have to be at like a coffee shop on
a patio or on a walk a walk date is my
like top one favorite date all-time like
can we just go on a walk like move
together and also have that way like
silence isn't uncomfortable it's just so
much better like walk dates are my jam
and so many people especially like to go
back to the alcohol conversation it's
let's meet for drinks okay so let's go
to a bar a happy hour or whatever and it
just completely convolute the situation
not only the fact that you're doing
but more of the factor that you're in a
loud environment where you can't hear
the other person you are overstimulated
by everything that's going on around you
and if I want to know if I want to have
a long-term relationship with you I
actually want to sit down and get to
know you a little bit and so my first
three dates can never be Bar concert
movies comedy show anything that's like
raucous around me like I need to have
like concentration to be able to have a
conversation with a person I love it I
can Nestle I can just see the or hear
the discomfort coming from a lot of
people who think well yeah like that's
that's all well and good but like you
know that's that just sounds a bit so a
lame or boring and it's like okay so
what you're saying is the people you
choose to date are so uninteresting that
you can't bear to be around them without
something else to entertain you well no
no no it's just no that's that's yeah if
you have if you have a visceral response
at the moment to the suggestions that
Amanda's making that you shouldn't have
this kind of hyper hyper stimulated type
and normalized environment where there's
loads of stuff going on and if you've
got it's kind of just below your
breastbone kind of just above your
stomach if there's like a bit of a hot
feeling there and you're finding
yourself swallowing a lot that is
because it's triggering you and that
means that there's a little bit of
something for you to work on there
mm-hmm yeah it's just you know you have
to look at have an of course I've had my
days where you know those were the fun
days and though that was that was my
twenties that's great and if you're
still in your 20s like just don't you
know write this down listen to this in a
couple years and your yearn to thank me
so much more come back this episode
pennant flag it do whatever but so if
you're if you're in your 20s just go
have fun screw around do whatever you
deserve that time that's like your rite
of passage to do all of that but if
you're in a point where you actually
value your own time and you want to have
a meaningful connection with another
person you you can't do all of these
other things that just signal
transaction right and that's exactly
what any of these dates signal is okay I
don't I don't find you interesting or I
don't have enough faith in myself to be
interesting that we could go do one of
these other
we're we're a little less like
stimulated around us and frankly a
walking date there's plenty to stimulate
you're going to pass other people I mean
obviously you have to live in an
environment where that's it's warm
enough and whatnot but your that is the
ultimate stimulation you have things all
around you to talk about people you're
passing that you can comment on it just
gets your brain movie and I think that I
wish I could like trademark the walking
dates the walking dates a good idea yeah
I like his girl there's in I sound like
someone who's just lived and breathed
Neil Strauss is the game but the only
references I have from the guys side
there isn't an equivalent for guys of a
holistic approach for dating as there is
for girls there's just pickup artistry
at least if you're my age now there is
some slightly more good stuff and I'm
going to give you my number one book
guys for dating advice at the end of
this podcast so stick around for that
but there is a common held piece of
advice in dating that you shouldn't sit
opposite each other if you can't you
should try and sit a right angle so you
should try and send adjacent because it
is less confrontational it means that
you're both moving in the same direction
together but the walking day is actually
even a step up from that right that
you're kind of made the person turning
to them and then kind of going back to
the front and then turning to them
incorrect yeah like that yeah a little
bit of CBT going on for you though
okay so we got walking date what else my
dog is about to howl in the background
I'm sorry for anything you shaking it
out yeah it's okay so walking date um
you know I think oh and then really
really being clear at the end and going
back and and reviewing kind of the date
that you were on and what you liked
about that person what you didn't but
even before it like let me write back
around to before the date I know that
and you kind of alluded to the fact that
some of your listeners and I agree are
probably thinking oh well that's really
you know what if what if I'm not you
know able to talk to the person or what
if I'm not interesting or they're boring
and all of these things I you have to
hold in your heart that the person that
you're meeting across the table if
you're going to take a chance to meet
with
that that could be your potential
partner and you have to treat everyone
as such like that is another thing
that's really helped me level up
especially on dating apps where it's
really easy to say like oh they could
have just been really good at marketing
themselves but now like oh I have to go
on this date with a stranger and it's
and when you go into a date with that
mindset you automatically projected to
the person you're automatically held
back if you can just go in there and
imagine for a second like yes this could
be my person but not in like the crazy
way well yeah crazy but but that you're
treating them as if they could be your
person you're not holding a grudge on
them that you had to meet them on a
dating app or holding a grudge that this
is awkward or whatever it is that you're
like really giving it your all and you
want them to feel loved and appreciated
on in the conversation so that's -
infrastructure based piece of advice
that kind of link in with what you just
said that I've got for guys and girls
which is if you open the funnel in
Instagram or on a dating app your first
goal should be to get them off of that
and into what's up as quickly as
possible like if you get past the
obviously presuming that you think
they're sufficiently attractive that's
officially interesting like get them off
that because the platform that you are
on is coloring all of the interactions
for as long as you're the tinder girl it
you can be you can be like the fittest
most interesting Elon Musk in incarnate
in female form level of intellect girl
on the planet but for as long as you
were on tinder you're in the gutter and
so get yourself out of that as quickly
as possible okay and with that like this
sounds so bad but you need in my opinion
need you need a scalable option to be
able to get yourself off that sort of a
platform so come up with it come up with
a script come up with a funny little
joke I've got mine I can't say it
because then when us when I say it to
all the you know yeah see this is this
is a thing there's only there's a level
of transparency that you on this podcast
ladies and gentlemen I always said I was
going to be truthful with you but I
didn't always say that I was going to be
completely transparent but you need to
just have a thing and he
like just used that like if something
comes up naturally and you're like oh I
really think that I should tell you
about the best coffee shop in this let
me pin you the location on what's up or
whatever like kind of but it's just it
seems so contrived right like just come
up with a script and use that and like
when it's like okay it's time to pull
the pin if they say oh I don't really
have what's up I would do whatever
everyone's got it shut up yeah and then
so move them on okay so we got we got
the walking date we've got the LCF we've
got the intentional with using app when
you're using it it have a good
conversation starter don't just be a
passive conversation you have set up
your profile you know put some attention
to it don't just like Jack around and
put the neck the first five pictures on
your phone or find you know that's
that's just a big one like be
intentional with your profile everyone
if you are trying you're on a visual
service you have to have a visual
profile that's pleasing it doesn't mean
you have to look like a supermodel but
we just have to see what you look like
and who you are and and then just have a
little bit of a hope for who you're
meeting and what what's happening there
you know if you look at at dating apps
just like I have as at some point of
like oh this is just [ __ ] everyone's on
here it's just the same old thing over
and over then you'll get the same old
thing over and over and that's not the
result you're wanting if you want a
better result they put your mind to the
possibility that it could be in there or
just you know this sounds well no I
it's not masculine I mean it sounds
harsh coming from a woman but one of the
things that I tell my clients is if you
don't like dating apps at least uses
them for practice like you have an
endless pool here are dates you can go
on and completely [ __ ] up and then just
write like at least get yourself some
confidence and go out on these random
dates and then when you meet him in the
grocery store on the quinoa aisle you'll
have you know the confidence because
you've already had a feminine hygiene in
erectile dysfunction I'll yeah exactly
so I got I got a couple of things that
I've come up with recently actually
they've pop yeah my head so one of them
is another concept from pickup artistry
which is called ashume attraction and
assume attraction is exactly as it says
on the tin that you are the prize
so that's the subheading ashume
attraction is the concept and you are
the prize is the subheading
what it means is that you need to go
into a situation with it doesn't matter
how hot the other person is or how
interesting are how intimidating the
other person is you know all of your
uniqueness your quirks all of the
different life experiences that you have
that makes you incredibly unique and
this person is just Jonathan or Leanne
or whatever it might be like they're
just a person you are you you have all
of these real different colorful
interesting things even if you think
that you're boring as hell you're not
because you've got twenty thirty forty
however many years of experiences behind
you you are the prize and if you go into
the situation with that in your mind it
will come across in the way that you
project yourself it will also make you a
lot less worried about failure or about
being rejected so for instance my life
comes first and then you will attach
onto the side of that you are the prize
and it's the equivalent I got a friend
Alex Arcana being on this podcast he is
a big atheist podcaster and he sat down
with Richard Dawkins the guy that
created new atheism and I was like dude
we he's only twenty years old this kid
he's a freak freak Savage crazy clever
Oxford you need in philosophy and I was
like we're not we're not worried oh
you're not like nervous or whatever and
he was like no no I was nervous for
Richard like he's fortunate to get to
sit down with me yeah like my podcast is
the thing that he's here to be on I'm
not here to be on his show he's here to
be on my show and as soon as he taught
me that and I was like holy [ __ ] and now
every guy like Ben Greenfield came on
here and else I it's fortunate for Ben
to be on my show
Ryan holidays just confirmed to be on
this podcast I'm like ah that's gonna be
fun for Ryan to be on this show you know
like I'm not going into it even if it's
you know that you're kind of gaming it a
little bit there's your thoughts become
the intentions quite quickly and you're
like yeah actually I am I am like a bit
of a badass like there's no reason that
I should I shouldn't be like owning this
girl who drives a 911 is in penthouses
and all this stuff you know I mean right
right exactly you know that's that's a
great perspective to take because if you
don't then you you're coming to it from
the perspective of I don't have enough
so I have to find that extra something
that I
don't have within you and that's never
it's never gonna work you're always
picking based on an emptiness that you
have that you think the other person can
fulfill 100% so that's that's my that's
my first thing yeah Shoom attraction and
you are the prize I've already said like
get yourself out of the app and this
goes for guys and girls I also think
that this is why Instagram is a
underused is a better to use dating app
then tinder is obviously you can't
refine your search criteria as as
efficiently but you get to see a lot
more of the other person you can work
out mutual connections more effectively
and also you're never going to be like
the tinder girl or the tinder guy you'll
just be their Instagram girl or the
Instagram guy which again actually just
raises that level of conversation up
just a little bit more it makes you
think well this is this is kind of kind
of a little bit more normal
I said that was going to give my my
favorite book and this would be really
cool for you to actually get most common
dating errors that you see from guys and
girls and then any resources and stuff
like that and obviously like your own
stuff and for sure sure but me for girls
I'm sorry I I think on the whole I think
girls are pretty good daters I think
that you're always gonna say this right
but like I I think that guys guys just
suck at dating like I I'm friends with
too many young lads to know to even
believe that guys are competent today
and they just suck right and like
there's some guys are pigs including me
at times in my past not now obviously
angel but my favorite book models by
Mark Manson so it's the first month that
he ever wrote and it was how to attract
women through honesty which has
depending on where you're coming from it
looking at it it could be like a real
Mincey kind of like fluffy title or a
really transactional like that's kind of
mean title but it's it's just how do you
as a guy maximize who you are to a girl
it lays out a really robust framework of
neediness which he thinks is the prime
driver
of Attraction in relationships how needy
one person is and how the other is and
it Maps pretty accurately to reality so
models by Marc Munson if you listen to
the audio book there's an updated
version which is about six hours long
inaudible and it is it's awesome I'll
link it it'll be I'll put it in the show
notes below in fact Amara Munson I'll
put it in the show notes below if you
want to go and pick it up bonus round
david deida the way of the superior man
now that is a little bit more whoo-whee
it talks a lot about masculine and
feminine energies and stuff probably an
interesting read more of an interesting
read for girls than models is but way
the superior man very much talks about
how as a man you should be the
principles that you should be leading
your life by basically there's some
intergenic sand some relationship stuff
in there but there's other stuff to do
with how you deal with relationship and
career challenges how you deal with
moving into a new epoch of your life and
all these sorts of stuff so that's my I
don't have a big a big repository of
dating advice which potentially I should
do given the fact as I've said my dating
life so fairly terrible but I mean I
give the floor to you so what first up
what are the main errors you see girls
making when they try and date I think it
is being either too agreeable like I
just have to give everything to this
person I'll do whatever this person once
I'm going to completely change who I am
or act a different way and just not
standing in your confidence and your
Worth and and feeling like you have to
change or show up in a certain way to be
what that person wants or desires or
needs I you know that it's just it's
just part of the way that we women are
brought up and but you can reprogram it
if you notice it you can reprogram it
and oh geez what are some other ones I
think leaning to do not leaning too far
towards your masculine or your feminine
side right I think that that can be in
relationships for women that can be
something that's a little bit
detrimental because either you're trying
to like stand your ground and saying no
I'm this person you have to you have to
do whatever I want and then you your
to [ __ ] or you are the other way and
you're too agreeable to someone or
you're always like that's more of on the
in the psychology side that's more of
your the your the of geez I'm losing my
words now you're the anxious attached
person right you'll like you'll do
whatever that other person wants because
you need their love for them so bad
neither of those polarities are actually
that enjoyable to be around as a guy I
can't speak about what guys are like in
that relation for girls but as a guy it
feels like whoever it is is playing a
role now that could be your true
personality you could be the 99 out of
100 agreeable person or you could be the
99 out of 100 disagreeable person that
could be you yeah the fact that there's
so little nuance to the way that you
operate the fact that like everything
that I say is rebutted with what I don't
agree with that I don't think that
that's right I like a scathing comment
or you know like whatever is if it's
just if I can ask you a question this is
the this is the [ __ ] heuristic I've
worked it out this is a heuristic to use
if I can ask you a question and I can
predict your answer before you answer it
mmm that's it and think about sink about
some of the people that you've spoken to
recently if you're single obviously if
you're not single like get off this get
off this podcast like your partner off I
don't but uh yeah think about the the
sweet people you've been speaking to
like can you predict their answers can
you ask them a question or said like say
something make a statement to them and
can you kind of ballpark guess where
their answers going to be and if they're
cut if you can't like what are you doing
like that's the same that is the same as
dating event requests to me mm-hmm
yeah absolutely for sure man and and it
just shows it just goes to show that
that's that person saying they're
marrying what they think is going to be
satisfying for you right and sorry
you've heard it before like guess what
it we we've both been in that in that
situation and it's so [ __ ] where
just performing for the other person and
when you find the person that is your
person I just have to believe that it's
like two fingers like folding hands if
you can't if you're not watching video
it's like you're folding your hands in
prayer they just like fit together and
you don't have to do this like
performative [ __ ] that you've been
doing your entire life and you know I'll
just right back to what I said in the
first part that I really want to drive
home that if you find that you are keep
continuing to attract the same type of
person you have to ask yourself what is
it that person is mirroring to me that
I'm supposed to be seen that the
universe is like hello sister hello
brother like we've shown you this five
times we're reflecting right to you what
you need to friggin fix in yourself and
you are ignoring it time after time like
if you keep attracting that same
frustrating undesirable you know
deal-breaker characteristic ask yourself
how that is in you or how you're asking
for that because it's safe it's you hit
the nail in the head before that you are
the common denominator absolutely you
are so reading mark Munson's models
there's two red pills that are oh
they're so large that I almost couldn't
swallow them so the first one the first
one was it was essentially that that you
are the common denominator in all of
your relationship failings hmm like
people that say guys who saying I've
been I've been like your subject of this
as well I do it I did it where you say
all of the girls in my town of [ __ ]
mm-hmm all of the girl or every the
entire female population in your town
that all of them are [ __ ] yes mmm
no no it yeah all the girls you meet a
[ __ ] or all of the girls respond to
you in a way which makes them seem like
[ __ ] that is the trip and that's the
same for girls as well if you say oh you
know that is all that all the guys in in
my city that just all [ __ ] what I need
to move to that it's Italy like if I was
in Rome
none of this and that's that that's the
myth the myth is I've got to move out of
my small town big city
yeah whatever country is to find myself
x-a a guy that has this a girl that does
that they're just not open-minded enough
they're not free-flowing enough there to
this that too they don't have any dreams
of any girls you like you are the common
denominator here and yeah [ __ ] that
hurts to swallow like yeah [ __ ] that you
are the architect of your own misery
well that reminds me of I'm gonna give
you two examples because I know we
probably need to wrap up but for that I
will say as someone who has moved across
state you know two states away to kind
of like reinvent my life the thing that
you have to remember is wherever you go
there you'll be it's one of my favorites
gone no and you know it's something
that's a little bit nuanced about doing
this inventory of who you dated before I
will tell you the thing that I found
that was a common denominator that was
weird and it really made me have to do a
lot of self-reflection so some of them
can be quite obvious but some of them
you might have to dig a little deeper
and one for me was every man who I've
had a significant relationship with he
has been just recently coming out of
another significant relationship
unwittingly done by me like I wasn't
sitting there like oh you just got out
of a relationship great you're freed up
let's go on a date that wasn't my mo
some of it I didn't even know until we
were involved but there was something in
me that as like a fixer or something was
attracting someone who needed to feel
safe or needed to you know whatever it
was that they were looking for haven't
quite deconstructed that yet so
listeners if you if you want to help me
out there do that but there's that's
mind blowing like every person coming
out of a significant relationship and so
that just says there's something to me
that I need to work out that is stops
attracting that and so I have a book for
that so let me tell you my book records
so one is it's not a dating book at all
guys and girls could use this um men and
women you might even say for the older
crowd listening it's called dark side of
the light chasers and it is all about
shadow work and I think that your
listeners are probably self actualized
enough to do this type of work and it's
really just drilling down to what are
those things in my psyche and my and my
own self identification that I am hiding
and from and avoiding that if I could
face it I could really change what I'm
attracted
my life and you know for me I think that
if I can solve that one I'll know I
attracted all of these guys that are
just out of a relationship but it goes
into so many other areas then two other
books I'll recommend just on just really
getting yourself in the right place
women one that I really love is a book
by Marianne Williamson called a woman's
worth super good book for gals it's a
really short read too it's like a teeny
tiny book and then just for everyone in
terms of personal development and
impossibility my favorite book ever is
power of intention by Wayne Dyer and
that's what sort of my personal
development journey and I can't
recommend that enough as just like an
eye-opening look into self-actualization
I haven't read any of those I maybe
don't read a woman it's worth you
probably could skip that one but the
other two you need to read okay yeah
that's that's awesome it's so cool when
you find like when you hear from someone
this is the book that changed my life
and you're like I didn't even know so
here's my he was the second red pill
actually we'll finish on that and then I
want you to tell everyone where they can
check out your stuff cuz you're awesome
the second red pill that I had to
swallow was to do with state changes and
the sense you have and the excuses that
you make before meeting someone going to
spend time with someone perhaps going
home with someone and it's a defense
mechanism it's an evolutionarily
programmed defense mechanism and me the
reason it hurt me so bad was because
I've been reading tons of Eve psych
recently evolutionary biology and I
thought I had this stuff down and I was
like I understand why prides there holy
[ __ ] I understand why I feel good when
I'm working and oh my god I understand
what loneliness is that's what that
isn't blah blah blah and then it's like
oh no this is so much more pervasive
than you thought it is everything so
that basically if you are a guy or a
girl and you can think back to a time
where perhaps you have been having
either
serious or a casual encounter with
someone who's either existing or new
probably actually not only someone who's
new or realistically only someone that's
new and um you felt some sort of
resistance come up in why you shouldn't
go over to their house let them over to
your house go on the day do the thing
and the front of your brain has given
you this really logic well maybe I'm
just not that attractive I'm so tired
got this knee ache I got this like it's
real it's man it's the outside him and
me you know like the kind of the back
like you just come up with these things
you rationalize these reasons but it's
not it's like you are attracted to this
person you were attracted to this person
previously you've been attracted to them
for ages maybe you've even thought about
getting physical with them in the past
mm-hmm why now are you somehow talking
yourself out of it and it is this fear
of state change we like being in the
cave that you know yes we know we know
this cave safe the one next door that
might though there might be a
saber-toothed tiger in there [ __ ] that I
don't want to go in there it's like yeah
there's not saber-toothed tiger in there
there is just a guy or a girl in a bed
and you need to be aware of that you
need to know right okay am i saying I'm
not attracted to the my knee hurts too
much untied works gonna start in the
morning or is it is that because you
have a fear of going to see them or is
it more genuine than that is this okay
rubber meets the road time now like I
really need to work out whether or not
I'm sufficiently physically attracted to
them um but I like looking back the
number of times where and you think that
our guys should just be hot to trot all
the time the number of times where I've
been like
some excuse on whatsapp I like because
don't know didn't have a reason just did
it just did it and I'm like yeah I know
I was in Tesco car park at Tesco car
park in Kenton it was only a couple of
weeks ago when I listened to this bit of
models from mark Monson and I was like
walking around in this dais reflecting
on all of the different times where I've
done that to myself I'm like ah you
absolute dick like just talking to my
own amygdala like just speak to the base
of my brain like you and it just had me
I was like that's it I've said I've come
up with so many excuses so many times
though I can't say you don't to see what
do this thing I'll just say what
happened at the time or whatever it is
and it's just fear of change that's it
right yeah the misery that you're in is
is more you know a you know that that
feels like so it's much better than like
the misery that you could be in
somewhere else that's unknown one more
book recommendation and for that with
relationships this is an old-school book
but it's still super relevant it's
called conscious loving by gay and Katy
Hendrix and they discuss kind of like
pleasure limits and upper limits that
you have in your relationship where you
won't like oh well if I let myself a
cheap happiness then it's only that
easier to get like dragged back down and
be hurt again
it's a really good book it kind of
focuses on people in relationships but
you can still read it as a single person
and get a lot out of it that's awesome
I wonder this this has been really fun
we've been talking about doing it for
ages I don't get you back on so girls
think that you cool they want to work
with you I know that you own
do you still only work with girls at the
moment I only work with women yeah it's
just easier for me honestly and I work
with women who specifically are alcohol
free or sober curious if you want to
hear more about the dating stuff that
I'm into I have a whole course on dating
honestly guys could purchase it too I
just wouldn't work with you one on one
the dating course you can find on my
site authentically Amanda forward slash
mindful dating and it's it goes through
everything we went through here but in
so much more detail of how I want you to
be intentional how I want you to grow
and improve your self-worth so you can
be the partner that you
call in and then how you interact on
dating apps and in the world real world
how to set up your profile like all that
stuff it's all like laid out in there
with plenty of exercises it's an
explanation you go all the cheat codes
in there as well all the best open it oh
that's yes my best opener it is in there
never fails never fail that's so good
look under everything that we've spoken
about among these fantastic socials will
be linked below icon I can't sing your
praises enough you've been awesome
you've been doing some cool stuff
recently in the sober community and it's
so nice as well like I think we've both
spoken about this privately but to see
someone who is from that side of the
community but also is really pushing the
envelope in other areas like okay so how
can i how can I use the insights I've
gained from my personal development and
my growth to make girls better at dating
or to be better wives or better mothers
or whatever it might be it's it's so
sick if you've enjoyed this episode tell
me and I'll get Amanda back on we've got
as you can tell we're just like buddies
China way so you know we can do this all
day
Amanda thank you so much
[Music]